- ברוכים השבים להבנת
מידע קוונטי וחישוב.
שמי John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני
של IBM Quantum Education.
זהו השיעור השלישי בסדרה. בשני השיעורים הראשונים, דיברנו על היסודות
של מידע קוונטי.
קודם על מערכות בודדות בבידוד ואז על מערכות מרובות.
דיברנו גם על מדידות
בסיס סטנדרטי ופעולות יוניטריות הן בהגדרות של מערכת בודדת והן
של מערכות מרובות.
בשיעור הזה, נציג
את מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי, שנותן לנו דרך סטנדרטית לתאר חישובים קוונטיים,
ואנחנו יכולים גם להשתמש ב-circuit קוונטיים כדי לתאר פרוטוקולים קוונטיים וסוגים אחרים של אינטראקציות שמערבות מכשירים קוונטיים מרובים.
בנוסף ל-circuit קוונטיים, נדון גם בכמה
מושגים מתמטיים חשובים הקשורים למידע קוונטי,
ונשתמש בהם כדי לראות
כמה מגבלות בסיסיות על מידע קוונטי ומה שאנחנו יכולים לעשות עם circuit קוונטיים.
זה יכין אותנו היטב
לשיעור שאחרי זה שבו נראה כמה
דוגמאות חשובות מאוד וזה יסיים את
היחידה הראשונה של הסדרה
על היסודות של מידע קוונטי.
הנה סקירה של השיעור. נתחיל עם מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי ונראה איך הוא עובד.
אחר כך נדבר על
המושג הקריטי של מכפלה פנימית, וגם על אורתונורמליות והטלות,
שקשורים למכפלות פנימיות. לא דנו בדברים האלה
בשני השיעורים הראשונים, כי באמת לא
היינו צריכים, אבל עכשיו כן.
מכפלות פנימיות נותנות לנו
כלי מתמטי שפשוט אי אפשר בלעדיו.
פשוט לא נתקדם רחוק בהבנת מידע קוונטי
וחישוב בלי מכפלות פנימיות.
ובחלק השלישי של השיעור, נסתכל על כמה
מגבלות חשובות של מידע קוונטי.
בסופו של דבר, מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות זה לחקור דברים מעניינים
שאפשר לעשות עם מידע קוונטי, אבל כדי לעשות את זה ביעילות,
אנחנו צריכים להיות מודעים לכמה
דברים שאנחנו לא יכולים לעשות.
בפרט, נדון
במושג של פאזה גלובלית ולמה פאזות גלובליות לא רלוונטיות.
נראה ניסוח של
משפט אי-השכפול, שאומר לנו שמצבים קוונטיים אי אפשר להעתיק באופן כללי, ונראה ששני מצבים קוונטיים
אי אפשר להבחין ביניהם
באופן מושלם אלא אם הם אורתוגונליים, וזו מגבלה
בסיסית שחשוב להכיר.
הנושא הראשון של השיעור
הוא מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי, שהוא מודל חישוב
שנותן לנו דרך
לתאר חישובים קוונטיים.
מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי מבוסס
על מושג כללי יותר במדעי המחשב של circuit, ואפשר להגדיר הרבה
מודלים שונים של חישוב
שמבוססים על המושג הכללי הזה.
הרעיון הבסיסי הוא ש-circuit
מורכב מחוטים שנושאים מידע, ו-gate שמייצגים פעולות
שמופעלות על
המידע שנישא על ידי החוטים.
המונח circuit הוא בעצם
שם קצת מוזר לסוג כזה של מודל
כי המילה circuit
בדרך כלל מתייחסת
למסלול מעגלי כלשהו.
אבל כשאנחנו מדברים על circuit
כמודלים של חישוב, אנחנו בדרך כלל מדברים
על circuit אציקליים
שבהם מסלולים מעגליים אסורים.
ליתר דיוק, לצורכי
הסדרה הזו, אנחנו נדרוש שמידע
תמיד יזרום משמאל לימין בכל circuit.
אז אם אתם מעדיפים, אתם
יכולים לחשוב על circuit כמתארים רצפים של פעולות שבהם הזמן הולך משמאל לימין.
הנה דוגמה של circuit בוליאני שבו החוטים נושאים ערכים
בינאריים, אפס או אחד,
וה-gate מייצגים
פעולות לוגיקה בוליאנית.
החוטים מיוצגים על ידי קווים, ופה יש לנו שני ביטים
של קלט שמסומנים X ו-Y,
ואם אנחנו רוצים לדעת
מה ה-circuit עושה על בחירה מסוימת של קלטים, אנחנו מעבירים את הערכים
על החוטים משמאל לימין,
בהתאם לפעולות
שה-gate מבצעים על הערכים
שנישאים על ידי החוטים.
אז למשל, אנחנו יכולים
לבדוק מה קורה כשמתחילים עם חוט הקלט העליון מוגדר לערך אחד וחוט הקלט
התחתון מוגדר לערך אפס.
שני חוטי הקלט האלה מובילים
לשתי הנקודות האלה ממש פה, שמייצגות פעולות פיצול, מה שאומר שהערך מועתק
כדי שאפשר יהיה להעביר אותו
קדימה לאורך מספר חוטים.
אז אם אנחנו עושים את זה, אז שני
החוטים האלה מקבלים את הערך אחד, שזה אותו דבר כמו זה, ושני החוטים האלה מקבלים את הערך אפס,
שזה אותו דבר כמו זה.
פה יש לנו gate NOT שמסומן
על ידי הסמל של שלילה לוגית, אז
הערך שיוצא הוא אפס,
שזו השלילה הלוגית של אחד. ובדומה, הערך
שיוצא מה-gate הזה הוא אחד שזו
השלילה הלוגית של אפס.
שני ה-gate האלה הם gate AND,
ה-gate הזה הוא gate OR, ואם נמשיך
ונעביר את הערכים
דרך ה-circuit, ונעריך
את ה-gate כמו שצריך, אז נראה שהערך הסופי
על החוט הזה פה הוא אחד.
אז כל ה-circuit מתאר
רצף של פעולות שמורכבות כפי שהאיור מציע, ובסוף מקבלים פונקציה
משני ביטים לביט אחד
במקרה הספציפי הזה. אבל באופן כללי, יכול להיות כל מספר
של ביטי קלט ופלט.
ה-circuit הספציפי הזה מחשב את ה-XOR של שני ביטי הקלט, אז הפלט הוא אחד
אם ורק אם בדיוק
אחד משני ביטי הקלט מוגדר לאחד והשני מוגדר לאפס, אבל זה לא באמת
חשוב, זו רק דוגמה.
זו עובדה בסיסית לגבי circuit בוליאניים שכל פונקציה מכל מספר ביטים לכל מספר ביטים אפשר לחשב
על ידי circuit בוליאני כלשהו, אם כי לפעמים אולי
תצטרכו circuit גדול מאוד כדי לחשב את הפונקציה
שמעניינת אתכם.
יש סגנונות אחרים שמשתמשים
בהם כדי לתאר circuit.
למשל, האיור הזה
מייצג בדיוק את אותו circuit כמו קודם, בסגנון שאולי יותר אופייני
להנדסת חשמל, שבו יש מוסכמות לצורות שמייצגות gate שונים.
אנחנו לא הולכים להשתמש
בסגנון הזה, אבל כן נציג
כמה סמלים משלנו ל-gate קוונטיים שונים, כמו gate Hadamard,
gate NOT מבוקר,
gate Toffoli, וכן הלאה.
רק כהערת אגב, פה אפשר לראות את המקור
של המונח circuit.
בהקשר של הנדסת חשמל, זה מאוד טבעי
לחשוב על חשמל שמסתובב ב-circuit.
אבל בסדרה הזו אנחנו לא
מדברים על חשמל שנע דרך circuit, אנחנו מדברים על מידע
שנע דרך circuit.
ושוב, אצלנו הם תמיד יהיו אציקליים, כשהמידע
נע משמאל לימין.
הנה דוגמה שונה של
סוג אחר של circuit שנקרא circuit אריתמטי.
הפעם החוטים מאחסנים מספרים וה-gate מייצגים
פעולות אריתמטיות כמו חיבור וכפל.
פה אפשר לראות דוגמה
של circuit אריתמטי.
זה לא חשוב לצורך
השיעור הזה מה הוא עושה, זו רק דוגמה שנועדה
להעביר את הרעיון שיש מושגים
שונים של circuit.
אנחנו יכולים גם לחשוב על
circuit שמערבים אקראיות, למשל, שבהם ה-gate מייצגים
פעולות הסתברותיות, ואם בא לכם,
אתם בטח יכולים לשבת כל היום ולחלום על מודלים חדשים של חישוב שמבוססים על המושג של circuit.
במודל ה-circuit הקוונטי,
החוטים מייצגים qubit, וה-gate מייצגים גם פעולות יוניטריות וגם מדידות.
הנה דוגמה מאוד פשוטה
של circuit קוונטי.
יש רק qubit אחד ב-circuit הזה, שמיוצג
על ידי הקו האופקי, וה-gate, שמסומנים
על ידי ריבועים,
מייצגים פעולות יוניטריות שמבוצעות על ה-qubit הזה.
אז אין מדידות
בדוגמה הספציפית הזו.
אם אנחנו רוצים לתת
ל-qubit שם כמו X, אפשר לציין את זה בתרשים על ידי הוספת X ממש
פה, זה אופציונלי.
בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו ב-circuit הבוליאני מלפני כמה רגעים, אפשר לחשוב על ה-circuit הזה
כמייצג רצף של פעולות שבהם הזמן
הולך משמאל לימין.
אז מתחילים עם X,
מפעילים את ה-gate הראשון, שהוא gate Hadamard
ואחריו gate S,
אז עוד gate Hadamard,
ולבסוף gate T.
ראינו את הפעולות האלה
לקראת סוף שיעור אחד, ופה אפשר לראות
את תיאורי המטריצות שלהם.
אז כשמבצעים את ארבע
הפעולות האלה לפי הסדר, כלומר קודם H, אז
S, אז H שוב, ואז T,
הפעולה המשולבת ניתנת
על ידי המכפלה הזו ממש פה, עם זכירה שהסדר
בעצם מתהפך
כמו שדיברנו בשיעור אחד. אם מבצעים את כפל המטריצות, מקבלים את המטריצה הזו ממש פה,
ואז הפעולה של ה-circuit
על ה-qubit X מתוארת על ידי המטריצה היוניטרית הזו.
לפעמים נרצה לציין במפורש בתרשים circuit קוונטי
מה הקלט שאנחנו מזינים, ואפשר לעשות את זה כמו שרואים ממש פה.
במקרה הזה, אנחנו מזינים
Ket 0 לתוך ה-circuit.
זה די נפוץ. לעיתים קרובות לוקחים Ket 0 כמצב
המאותחל של qubit, אבל זה לא הכרחי.
אפשר גם לשקול
להפעיל את ה-circuit על מצב אחר.
אם בוחרים, אפשר גם
לציין את מצב הפלט שמקבלים ככה.
הנה דוגמה נוספת שבה
הפעם יש לנו שני qubit בשם X ו-Y כמו שרואים
בתרשים.
פה יש לנו gate Hadamard, שמופעל על ה-qubit Y, ואחריו ה-gate שמסומן על ידי
הסמל הזה ממש פה,
שהוא gate NOT מבוקר. דיברנו על פעולת
ה-NOT המבוקרת בשיעור הקודם,
ופה בתרשים הזה אנחנו
יכולים לראות שה-qubit המבקר הוא Y, שמסומן על ידי
העיגול הקטן המלא,
וה-qubit המטרה הוא X, שמסומן על ידי העיגול הגדול עם מה שנראה כמו סימן פלוס בתוכו.
זה קצת נראה כמו
הסמל של XOR אז זה הגיוני.
אפשר לדמיין שכל מצב קלאסי
שמאוחסן ב-Y עובר XOR על ה-qubit X.
ורק לשם בהירות, הנה התרשים שמראה
את הפעולה של ה-gate הזה על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי,
כשאנחנו מניחים ש-A
ו-B הם ערכים בינאריים.
למצבים אחרים, הפעולה נקבעת
על ידי לינאריות כמו תמיד.
עכשיו, לפני שממשיכים, יהיה שימושי
לציין במפורש מוסכמה שנעקוב אחריה לגבי איך qubit מסודרים
בתרשימי circuit קוונטי כמו זה.
והמוסכמה היא שסדר
מלמטה למעלה בתרשים circuit קוונטי שווה לסדר משמאל לימין
כמו ב-tuple או מכפלה טנזורית.
זו מוסכמה שנעקוב
אחריה בסדרה וזו גם המוסכמה
שמשמשת ב-Qiskit.
אז ל-circuit הספציפי הזה ממש פה, אנחנו חושבים עליו כפועל
על זוג qubit X, Y,
X בא קודם כי הוא למטה, ו-Y בא אחרון או שני במקרה הזה, כי הוא למעלה.
הדרך שאפשר לחשוב על
זה ויזואלית, למקרה שזה עוזר, היא לדמיין סיבוב
של ה-circuit עם כיוון השעון כך שהקלטים למעלה
והפלטים למטה, והסדר של
ה-qubit יהיה נכון.
לפעמים הסדר הזה מבלבל אנשים, אז פשוט תזכרו
את המוסכמה הזו.
אז כשחושבים על הפעולה שה-circuit הזה מתאר, מה שיש קודם זה
gate Hadamard שמופעל על Y
ואז gate NOT
מבוקר על שני ה-qubit כש-Y הוא המבקר
ו-X הוא המטרה.
אם רוצים לרשום מטריצה יוניטרית שמתארת את הפעולה
המשולבת של שני ה-gate האלה, אפשר לעשות את זה.
קודם, נתייחס ל-gate Hadamard על Y.
אנחנו מפעילים את ה-gate Hadamard על Y ולא עושים כלום ל-X, מה ששקול
לביצוע פעולת זהות על X.
ואז הפעולה של ה-gate Hadamard על שני ה-qubit ביחד ניתנת
על ידי המכפלה הטנזורית של מטריצת הזהות ו
המטריצה שמייצגת
את פעולת Hadamard על Y.
זה נראה ככה, עם זכירת
המוסכמה שלנו ש-X בא קודם ו-Y בא שני, אז זה
זהות טנזור H.
אז מפעילים את פעולת
ה-NOT המבוקרת, שיש לה את ייצוג
המטריצה הזה, ושוב, זה עקבי עם המוסכמה שלנו.
ה-qubit השני Y הוא המבקר וה-qubit הראשון X הוא המטרה.
אל תפחדו לעצור את הסרטון ולוודא שזה הגיוני ואני אפסיק להזכיר לכם את זה.
אתם יכולים לעצור את הסרטונים האלה, לחזור אחורה ולצפות בחלקים
כמה פעמים שרוצים, לשנות את מהירות ההפעלה אם בוחרים, להשתמש בהם בכל
דרך שעובדת הכי טוב בשבילכם.
בכל מקרה, כשמרכיבים את
שתי הפעולות יחד, הפעולה המשולבת מתוארת
על ידי המכפלה הזו ממש פה,
ושתי המטריצות האלה
מוכפלות בסדר הזה כי ה-Hadamard מבוצע קודם וה-NOT
המבוקר מבוצע שני,
ושוב, זה עקבי
עם מה שדיברנו עליו בשיעור אחד שבו הסדר
בעצם מתהפך.
אם מבצעים את כפל המטריצות, מקבלים את המטריצה הזו ממש פה.
ועכשיו אפשר לקרוא מהמטריצה הזו מה ה-circuit עושה
למצבי בסיס סטנדרטי.
אם מריצים את ה-circuit על הקלט 0, 0, כלומר Ket 0 ל-qubit הראשון, Ket 0 ל-qubit השני,
התוצאה היא מצב Bell Phi+, שאפשר לראות מ
העמודה הראשונה של המטריצה.
אם מזינים 0, 1, מקבלים את מצב Phi-, אחד אפס נותן לנו את מצב Psi+,
ו-1, 1 נותן לנו לא Psi-, אלא מינוס 1 כפול Psi-.
סימן המינוס לא
באמת משמעותי פה. אם לא הייתם רוצים את זה פה, הייתם יכולים לבצע פעולת swap
על שני ה-qubit
כדי להיפטר מזה ולא
הייתם מקלקלים את מה שקרה לשלושת מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי הראשונים.
אבל זה באמת לא חשוב
לצורך הדוגמה הזו.
אז לסיכום, ל-circuit יש את הפעולה הזו ממש פה על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי.
כשחושבים על
מה circuit מסוים עושה, לא חייבים לעבור דרך
ההמרה למטריצות ולהכפיל אותן יחד,
אפשר גם לעקוב אחר
הפעולה שה-circuit מבצע על מצבים מסוימים, ובמקרים רבים זו תהיה
האפשרות המועדפת.
בדוגמה הזו, למשל, אפשר לראות מה ה-circuit
עושה למצב 0, 0 על ידי בחינת הפעולה של ה-gate.
המצב ההתחלתי, שקראנו
לו Pi אפס פה, רק כדי להימנע משם
שיתבלבל עם מצבי Bell הוא 0, 0.
מפעילים את ה-gate Hadamard והמצב שמקבלים הוא 0+ שאפשר לפרוש אותו ככה,
ואז פעולת ה-NOT המבוקרת לוקחת את המצב הזה למצב Phi+, שאפשר לראות על ידי חשיבה
על הפעולה שה-NOT המבוקר מבצע על
מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי,
ואפשר לעשות את אותו
דבר לשלושת מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי האחרים או לכל
מצב אחר לצורך העניין.
אפשר גם לשלב ביטים קלאסיים בתרשימי circuit קוונטי.
הם מסומנים על ידי
קווים כפולים כמו שרואים בתרשים הזה.
כלומר A ו-B הם ביטים קלאסיים ו-X ו-Y הם qubit.
יש לנו את אותם שני gate יוניטריים כמו בדוגמה הקודמת, והסמלים האלה ממש פה מייצגים מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי
ספציפית אחרי ששתי הפעולות
היוניטריות מבוצעות, מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי
מבוצעת על Y
והתוצאה נכתבת מחדש
לביט הקלאסי B, ובדומה X נמדד והתוצאה נכתבת לביט A.
פה אפשר לראות שה-qubit X ו-Y ממשיכים הלאה אחרי שנמדדו.
אבל זה די נפוץ
שלא ממש אכפת לנו מ-qubit
אחרי שנמדדו.
לפעמים כל מה שמעניין אותנו
זה תוצאת המדידה. ובמקרה כזה, אפשר להשתמש בקיצור
שרואים פה
שבו למדידות נכנסים qubit ויוצאים ביטים קלאסיים.
ההבנה פה היא שברגע
שה-qubit נמדדים, הם פשוט נזרקים או מתעלמים מהם ותוצאת המדידה
הקלאסית מועברת הלאה.
עכשיו ככל שהסדרה תמשיך, נראה הרבה
דוגמאות של circuit קוונטיים והם בדרך כלל
יהיו הרבה יותר מסובכים מהדוגמאות
הפשוטות מאוד שראינו.
כמו שהזכרתי קודם, סמלים שונים משמשים
ל-gate שונים.
gate של qubit בודד בדרך כלל
נכתבים כריבועים עם אות שמציינת
איזו פעולה זו.
לפעמים ה-gate השונים
האלה מקודדים בצבעים שונים כדי לייצג דברים שונים, אבל
נתעלם מזה לעת עתה.
כבר ראינו את
ה-gate NOT המבוקר.
gate swap מסומנים
כמו שרואים ממש פה, ו-gate Toffoli ו-gate Fredkin
מסומנים כמו שרואים ממש פה.
זכרו ש-gate Toffoli הוא gate NOT מבוקר-מבוקר ו-gate Fredkin הוא
gate swap מבוקר.
אז הסמלים האלה
עקביים עם הרעיון ש-qubit מבקר
מסומן על ידי עיגול מלא עם קו שמחבר אותו
ל-gate שהוא שולט בו.
באופן כללי, qubit מבקרים
לא חייבים להיות למעלה וה-gate האלה לא חייבים
לפעול על qubit שכנים, מה שאומר שה-gate
האלה יכולים להימתח מעל
qubit אחרים שהם לא פועלים עליהם, ונראה את זה
קורה בשיעורים הבאים.
עוד דבר שלעיתים קרובות עושים כשמשתמשים במודל ה-circuit הקוונטי הוא להתייחס לפעולות יוניטריות שרירותיות
על כל מספר של qubit
כאילו הם gate בודדים כמו שרואים ממש פה.
פשוט על ידי ציור מלבן עם תווית שמתאימה
לכל פעולה יוניטרית שזו.
במקרה הזה זו איזושהי
פעולה יוניטרית U.
כמובן, אנחנו לא יודעים
מה U מהתרשים הזה, צריך להניח ש-U
מוגדר איכשהו או שאנחנו מתייחסים לאיזושהי פעולה
יוניטרית שרירותית U, אולי. זה יכול להיות למשל
שאנחנו רוצים לחשוב על U כאילו הוא תת-שגרה
למען הבהירות.
אנחנו גם משתמשים בסימון
הזה שרואים ממש פה לפעולת U מבוקרת
שבה ה-qubit המבקר מסומן על ידי עיגול מלא
בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו קודם.
אז זו הייתה הקדמה קצרה
למודל ה-circuit הקוונטי. וכמו שאמרתי קודם, נראה הרבה יותר
דוגמאות של circuit קוונטיים
ככל שנמשיך בסדרה.
בחלק הבא של השיעור, נסתכל על
מכפלות פנימיות, אורתונורמליות והטלות, שהם מושגים חשובים מאוד
במידע קוונטי וחישוב.
נתחיל עם מכפלות פנימיות.
זכרו שכשמשתמשים
בסימון דירק, Ket הוא וקטור עמודה
ו-Bra הוא וקטור שורה,
וספציפית וקטור
ה-Bra שמתאים לוקטור עמודה נתון הוא הצמוד המשוחלף
של וקטור העמודה הזה.
אז לוקטור הזה ממש פה, מקבלים את וקטור ה-Bra המתאים על ידי שחלוף הוקטור
כאילו הוא מטריצה,
מה שזה בעצם להניח אותו על הצד ואז לקחת את הצמוד המרוכב של כל אחת מהכניסות.
עכשיו, נניח שיש לנו שני Ket עם אותו מספר כניסות ככה.
אם ניצור את הסוגריים האלה ממש פה, שפשוט אומר
שלוקחים את המכפלה של ה-Bra וה-Ket,
כאילו הם מטריצות,
אז מקבלים את הביטוי
הזה שרואים ממש פה, שהוא סקלר, או במילים
אחרות מספר מרוכב.
הערך הזה נקרא המכפלה
הפנימית של שני הוקטורים האלה.
אפשר גם לחשוב על מכפלות פנימיות במונחים של וקטורים בצורה
שרואים ממש פה שבה הוקטורים מבוטאים
כצירופים לינאריים
של וקטורי בסיס סטנדרטי.
המכפלה הפנימית של הוקטורים האלה מוגדרת באותו אופן כמו
קודם, Bra Psi כפול Ket Phi שאפשר לבטא
כמכפלה ככה.
ואם מחשבים ומפשטים, נשארים עם הביטוי הזה ממש פה למכפלה הפנימית, שהוא אנלוגי למה שהיה לנו קודם,
חוץ מזה שהפעם אנחנו
סוכמים על אלמנטים בקבוצת המצבים הקלאסית שלנו, שהיא sigma במקרה הספציפי הזה.
הנה דוגמה שנועדה לתת לכם תמונה גיאומטרית של
איך מכפלות פנימיות עובדות.
פה ציירתי עיגול
במרחב דו-ממדי שמתאים ל-qubit, וכל עוד מגבילים את תשומת הלב
לוקטורים עם כניסות של מספרים ממשיים, אפשר לצייר אותם כנקודות על המישור הזה.
ניקח את Phi להיות
הוקטור הזה ממש פה.
זה וקטור יחידה, שאפשר לראות על ידי
חישוב הנורמה האוקלידית וזה מה שהעיגול הזה מייצג,
זה כל וקטורי היחידה
עם כניסות של מספרים ממשיים.
ניקח גם את Psi להיות
הוקטור הזה ממש פה, שגם הוא וקטור יחידה.
זה בעצם מצב המינוס, אבל פה אנחנו פשוט קוראים לו Psi.
אם מחשבים את המכפלה
הפנימית של שני הוקטורים האלה, מקבלים אחד מינוס שורש שלוש חלקי שניים כפול שורש שניים,
שזה בקירוב מינוס רבע.
הערך של המכפלה הפנימית הזו שווה לקוסינוס של הזווית
בין שני הוקטורים, שאפשר לראות פה באיור.
זה משהו שנכון
באופן כללי לוקטורי יחידה. אם יש לנו שני וקטורי יחידה ולשניהם כניסות של מספרים ממשיים,
אז המכפלה הפנימית ביניהם שווה לקוסינוס של
הזווית ביניהם.
בפרט, אם המכפלה
הפנימית שווה לאפס, כמו בדוגמה הזו, שבה שינינו את Psi
להיות המצב הזה ממש פה,
אז שני הוקטורים חייבים
להיות בזווית של 90 מעלות זה לזה.
כל זה מוכלל גם
לוקטורים בכל ממד, אגב, כל עוד
הכניסות הן מספרים ממשיים, זה לא רק לוקטורים דו-ממדיים.
אם יש כניסות של מספרים מרוכבים, התמונה לא באמת
עובדת יותר, אבל בכל זאת, המכפלה הפנימית שימושית
לא פחות כמו שנראה.
למכפלה הפנימית יש כמה
תכונות חשובות מאוד ונקדיש כמה רגעים כדי לראות חלק מהתכונות האלה עכשיו.
ראשית, קשר
בין המכפלה הפנימית והנורמה האוקלידית.
אם לוקחים את המכפלה
הפנימית של וקטור כלשהו עם עצמו, מקבלים את הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע.
אז אפשר לומר לחלופין שהנורמה האוקלידית של וקטור שווה לשורש
הריבועי של המכפלה הפנימית
של הוקטור עם עצמו. זה לא צירוף מקרים, זה
קשר בסיסי, ופה אפשר לראות שאם לא היו לנו
הצמודים המרוכבים בהגדרה של המכפלה הפנימית, אז הנוסחה
הזו לא הייתה נכונה יותר, ולא היה לנו מושג כל כך שימושי
עם הקשר הבסיסי הזה
לנורמה האוקלידית.
בנוסף, המכפלה הפנימית
היא סימטרית-צמודה, מה שאומר שאם מחליפים
את הסדר של שני הארגומנטים, אז הערך שמקבלים למכפלה
הפנימית עובר צימוד.
זה מבוטא על ידי
המשוואה הזו ממש פה וזה די ישיר לראות למה זה קורה לשני הביטויים האלה
של המכפלה הפנימית של שני הוקטורים בשני הסדרים האפשריים.
המכפלה הפנימית היא לינארית
בארגומנט השני. ספציפית, אם מגדירים וקטור Phi להיות הצירוף הלינארי
הזה של שני וקטורים,
Phi אחד ו-Phi שניים, אז המכפלה הפנימית של
וקטור כלשהו Psi עם Phi היא אותו צירוף לינארי
של שתי המכפלות הפנימיות,
וזה נובע די
ישירות מהעובדה שכפל מטריצות הוא לינארי.
ויש לנו גם שהמכפלה
הפנימית היא צמודה-לינארית בארגומנט הראשון, שאפשר לראות מבוטא ממש פה.
אם Psi הוא הצירוף
הלינארי הזה של וקטורים, אז אם לוקחים את
המכפלה הפנימית של Psi ו-Phi,
אז Bra Psi הופך לוקטור הזה שרואים ממש פה שבו לוקחים את
הצמוד המרוכב של ביתא אחד וביתא שניים,
ואז זו התוצאה וזה מה שהכוונה
בלינאריות-צמודה.
והתכונה האחרונה של המכפלה הפנימית שאני רוצה להזכיר היא
אי-השוויון של Cauchy-Schwarz שהוא שימושי להפליא.
לכל שני וקטורים, Psi ו-Phi, הערך המוחלט של המכפלה הפנימית אף פעם לא יכול להיות גדול יותר מ
המכפלה של הנורמות האוקלידיות
של שני הוקטורים. ויתר על כן, הדרך היחידה ששני
צדדי אי-השוויון יכולים להיות שווים היא אם שני
הוקטורים תלויים לינארית,
מה שאומר שאחד מהם שווה לסקלר כלשהו כפול השני.
זה בעצם אחד
מאי-השוויונות הנפוצים ביותר בכל המתמטיקה ו
אנחנו משתמשים בו שוב ושוב כשמדברים על
מידע קוונטי,
אז מאוד טוב לדעת עליו.
בשלב הבא, נדבר על
המושגים של אורתוגונליות ואורתונורמליות שקשורים
למכפלות פנימיות
וספציפית, למכפלות
פנימיות של וקטורים ששוות לאפס.
ליתר דיוק, אם יש לנו
שני וקטורים, Psi ו-Phi, אנחנו אומרים שהם אורתוגונליים
אם המכפלה הפנימית שלהם
שווה לאפס. והדרך שאפשר לחשוב
על וקטורים אורתוגונליים אינטואיטיבית היא שהם
בזוויות ישרות זה לזה,
או לחלופין, שהם
מאונכים זה לזה.
אנשים לפעמים משתמשים במונח אורתוגונלי כדי להתייחס לדברים שאין
להם שום קשר זה לזה, כמו לומר שנושא אחד
אורתוגונלי לאחר,
אבל זה כמובן די לא פורמלי ולא באמת משמעותי
במובן מתמטי, אבל הקשר ברור אם חושבים על וקטורים אורתוגונליים
כמצביעים
לא בכיוונים מנוגדים, אלא בכיוונים שונים לגמרי כמו צפון לעומת מערב למשל.
אם יש לנו קבוצה של וקטורים, אנחנו אומרים שהקבוצה היא קבוצה אורתוגונלית אם כל שני וקטורים שונים
שנבחרים מהקבוצה
בהכרח אורתוגונליים זה לזה, מה שאפשר לבטא
כמו שרואים ממש פה,
קבוצה אורתונורמלית היא
פשוט קבוצה אורתוגונלית של וקטורי יחידה.
וקטורים בקבוצות אורתוגונליות
לא בהכרח צריכים להיות וקטורי יחידה, ולמעשה אפשר
שאפילו וקטור האפס
יהיה אלמנט של קבוצה אורתוגונלית, אבל בקבוצה אורתונורמלית, כל וקטור חייב להיות וקטור יחידה
בנוסף לדרישה
שהקבוצה היא קבוצה אורתוגונלית.
בהינתן מה שאנחנו יודעים על הקשר בין המכפלה הפנימית
והנורמה האוקלידית, אפשר לבטא את
התנאי הזה בצורה תמציתית
כמו שרואים ממש פה.
ולבסוף, בסיס אורתונורמלי הוא פשוט קבוצה אורתונורמלית
שיוצרת בסיס לכל מרחב וקטורי
שמדברים עליו.
למשל, אם לוקחים כל
קבוצת מצבים קלאסית sigma וחושבים על הקבוצה של
כל וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי,
רואים שזו קבוצה אורתונורמלית ולמעשה זה בסיס אורתונורמלי למרחב של כל הוקטורים שהכניסות שלהם מתאימות
לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסית sigma הזו.
אלה כולם וקטורי יחידה
והם אורתוגונליים בזוגות, אז זו קבוצה אורתונורמלית.
ומכיוון שזה גם בסיס, יש לנו שזה בסיס אורתונורמלי.
קבוצות אורתונורמליות הן
תמיד בלתי תלויות לינארית אגב, אז בכל פעם שיש
קבוצה אורתונורמלית, היא תמיד תהיה בסיס אורתונורמלי
לתת-מרחב כלשהו,
אבל במקרה הזה, יש לנו בסיס לכל המרחב שעובדים בו.
דוגמה נוספת היא הקבוצה
שמכילה Ket+ ו-Ket-.
שני הוקטורים האלה אורתוגונליים, המכפלה הפנימית שלהם שווה לאפס.
ושניהם וקטורי יחידה והם פורשים את
המרחב הדו-ממדי של וקטורים שמתאימים ל-qubit בודד, אז הם יוצרים בסיס אורתונורמלי
למרחב הזה.
דוגמה נוספת היא בסיס Bell, שהוא בסיס אורתונורמלי למרחב של כל
הוקטורים ארבע-ממדיים שמתאימים לשני qubit.
הקבוצה שמכילה Ket 0
ו-Ket+ מצד שני, היא לא קבוצה אורתוגונלית כי המכפלה הפנימית בין
הוקטורים האלה אינה אפס.
שניהם וקטורי יחידה וזה בסיס למרחב הוקטורי שמתאים ל-qubit, אבל אין לנו אורתוגונליות.
הנה עובדה שימושית על קבוצות אורתונורמליות שנשתמש בה מדי פעם.
נניח שיש לנו איזושהי
קבוצה אורתונורמלית של וקטורים, ספציפית, בואו נניח
שיש לנו M וקטורים בקבוצה הזו, Psi אחד עד Psi M,
כשאנחנו מניחים שהוקטורים האלה נלקחים ממרחב וקטורי
N-ממדי כלשהו, או במילים אחרות, לכל אחד
מהוקטורים יש M כניסות.
כמו שכבר הזכרתי, קבוצות אורתונורמליות הן תמיד
בלתי תלויות לינארית, אז לא יכול להיות ש-M גדול מ-N,
אבל יכול להיות ש-M קטן מ-N, וזה המקרה
שמעניין אותנו.
ומה שהעובדה אומרת היא
שאם M קטן מ-N, אז תמיד אפשר
להוסיף וקטורים נוספים
לקבוצה שהתחלנו איתה כדי לקבל
בסיס אורתונורמלי למרחב שלנו.
ליתר דיוק, בהכרח
קיימים וקטורים Psi M+1 עד Psi N כך שכל האוסף
יוצר בסיס אורתונורמלי.
אז אף פעם אי אפשר לדחוק
את עצמכם לפינה, כביכול, על ידי בחירת
קבוצה אורתונורמלית של וקטורים שלא ניתן להרחיב
כדי ליצור בסיס אורתונורמלי.
לפעמים אפשר פשוט להסתכל
על הקבוצה שמתחילים איתה ולהבין איך להרחיב אותה כדי ליצור בסיס אורתונורמלי, אבל חלופה שתמיד עובדת
היא להשתמש בתהליך שנקרא תהליך האורתונורמליזציה
של Gram-Schmidt כדי לבנות את הוקטורים האלה.
לא אסביר את
התהליך הזה בשיעור הזה או בסדרה הזו כי הפרטים לא
באמת חשובים לנו, אבל כמובן אפשר
לחפש אם סקרנים.
זה משהו שמחשב
יכול לבצע למקרה שזה רלוונטי, אז
אין כאן יצירתיות מעורבת, זה פשוט תהליך מכני.
אחת הסיבות שזו
עובדה כל כך שימושית קשורה לקשר הדוק שקיים בין בסיסים אורתונורמליים
למטריצות יוניטריות.
בפרט, לכל מטריצה ריבועית U, שלושת התנאים שרואים פה הם תמיד שקולים,
מה שאומר שהם או
כולם נכונים או כולם לא נכונים.
התנאי הראשון אומר
ש-U היא מטריצה יוניטרית, מה שאומר שגם U dagger כפול U וגם U כפול U dagger שניהם
שווים למטריצת הזהות.
התנאי השני
אומר שהשורות של U יוצרות בסיס אורתונורמלי
והתנאי השלישי אומר שהעמודות של U
יוצרות בסיס אורתונורמלי.
זה בעצם לא כל כך קשה
לראות למה השקילות הזו נכונה.
רק כדי לשמור על פשטות, בואו נסתכל על
מטריצת U בגודל שלוש על שלוש כמו שרואים ממש פה, שבה הכניסות יכולות להיות כל
מספרים מרוכבים שרוצים.
פה בצד שמאל כתבתי את הצמוד המשוחלף של U
רק לנוחות.
אם יוצרים שלושה וקטורים
מהעמודות של U, שפה נקראים Psi
אחד, Psi שניים ו-Psi שלוש, אז אם לוקחים את
המכפלה של U dagger ו-U,
אפשר לבדוק שכל
כניסה של המכפלה ניתנת על ידי מכפלה פנימית של וקטורים כמו שרואים ממש פה בתבנית הזו.
ועכשיו כשחושבים על התנאי ש-U יוניטרית, ששקול לכך שהמטריצה הזו שווה למטריצת הזהות,
רואים שזה שקול לכך
ששלושת הוקטורים יוצרים קבוצה אורתונורמלית.
הכניסות על האלכסון
חייבות כולן להיות שוות לאחד, אז אלה בהכרח וקטורי יחידה, והכניסות מחוץ
לאלכסון חייבות להיות אפס,
אז זו קבוצה אורתוגונלית של וקטורים.
אז U יוניטרית זה שקול לכך שהעמודות יוצרות קבוצה אורתונורמלית,
וזה חייב להיות בסיס כי מספר הוקטורים בקבוצה, שהוא שלוש במקרה הזה, תואם את הממד של המרחב
שעובדים בו. אפשר לעקוב אחר טיעון דומה לשורות במקום לעמודות כדי להסיק ש-U יוניטרית
זה שקול
לכך שהשורות יוצרות בסיס אורתונורמלי.
זה לא עובד באותה נקיון כי צריך לעשות התאמה כדי שהצמודים המרוכבים
יעבדו בצורה הנכונה, אבל הרעיון זהה.
דרך חלופית לגשת לזה, שהיא די ישירה, היא להוכיח שמטריצה היא יוניטרית אם ורק אם המשוחלפת שלה יוניטרית.
ופה אני באמת מתכוון לומר משוחלפת ולא צמוד משוחלף.
זה די טריוויאלי מההגדרה
של מטריצות יוניטריות, שהצמוד המשוחלף
של כל מטריצה יוניטרית הוא יוניטרי,
אבל גם המשוחלפת של כל מטריצה יוניטרית היא יוניטרית.
בכל מקרה, יש לנו את
השקילות בין שלושת התנאים האלה על כל מטריצה ריבועית U, ואפשר לשלב את השקילות הזו
עם העובדה על
הרחבת קבוצות אורתונורמליות ליצירת בסיסים אורתונורמליים כדי לבנות מטריצות יוניטריות
שעושות דברים מעניינים
או ממלאות צרכים שונים שאנחנו עלולים להיתקל בהם.
ספציפית בכל פעם שיש
קבוצה אורתונורמלית של M וקטורים, תמיד תהיה קיימת מטריצה יוניטרית U
ש-M העמודות הראשונות שלה הן הוקטורים מהקבוצה האורתונורמלית.
את העמודות הנותרות
תמיד אפשר למלא כך שנקבל מטריצה יוניטרית על ידי בחירתן כך שהעמודות יוצרות
בסיס אורתונורמלי. זו תהיה עובדה
די שימושית שעומדת לרשותנו.
ועוד נושא אחד
לחלק הזה של השיעור הוא המושג של הטלה.
מטריצה ריבועית Pi
נקראת הטלה או מטריצת הטלה אם שתי התכונות
הרשומות פה שתיהן נכונות.
זה Pi גדולה אגב, זו בחירה די אופיינית לאות שמשמשת לסמן הטלה.
לעיתים קרובות נותנים שמות אופייניים כאלה לאובייקטים כמו מטריצות רק כדי שיהיה קל יותר לזהות ולשמור על סדר,
אבל אפשר להשתמש בכל שם שרוצים. בכל מקרה, התנאי הראשון הוא ש-Pi שווה לצמוד המשוחלף שלה עצמה.
באופן כללי, כשיש מטריצה ששווה לצמוד
המשוחלף שלה עצמה, אומרים שהיא מטריצה הרמיטית.
אז אפשר לנסח את התנאי הראשון לחלופין כ-Pi היא הרמיטית.
התנאי השני הוא
שאם מעלים את Pi בריבוע, כלומר כופלים את Pi
בעצמה, מקבלים Pi שוב.
אז העלאה בריבוע של Pi לא עושה לה כלום.
הרעיון של הטלה
באופן אינטואיטיבי הוא שזה דומה ברוחו
להקרנת תמונה על מסך או הורדת אנך על קו
למשל. כשכופלים
וקטור בהטלה, מה שעושים זה במובן מסוים
משאירים חלק ממנו כמו שהוא
ומאפסים את השאר.
אז אם מפעילים
הטלה פעם שנייה, היא לא עושה כלום כי
כבר איפסנו את החלק שההטלה מאפסת.
דוגמה להטלה
היא המטריצה הזו ממש פה לכל בחירה של וקטור יחידה Psi.
אפשר לבדוק שהיא מקיימת
את התנאים הנדרשים אחד אחד.
לתנאי הראשון, מחשבים
את הצמוד המשוחלף וזה הצמוד
המשוחלף של מכפלה.
ואז אפשר להשתמש בנוסחה הזו ממש פה לצמוד המשוחלף
של מכפלה כדי לעזור לנו.
מה שמקבלים זה מכפלת
הצמודים המשוחלפים, אבל הסדר מתהפך.
זה קורה בגלל
חלק השחלוף.
אז אם מפעילים את הנוסחה הזו, מקבלים את השוויון הזה ממש פה ואז אפשר לפשט כדי
לחזור למטריצה המקורית.
שימו לב אגב, שלא השתמשנו בעובדה
ש-Psi הוא וקטור יחידה.
אז למעשה, המטריצה הזו
הרמיטית לכל וקטור Psi, לא רק לוקטורי יחידה.
ולתנאי השני, מעלים את Pi בריבוע ומקבלים
את הביטוי הזה ממש פה וזה שווה למטריצה
המקורית הפעם
כי Psi הוא וקטור יחידה, אז המכפלה הפנימית
הזו ממש פה שווה לאחד וזה המקום שבו ההנחה
ש-Psi הוא וקטור יחידה
נכנסת לתמונה.
אפשר להכליל את הדוגמה הזו ולהתחיל עם קבוצה אורתונורמלית.
ואם יוצרים את המטריצה הזו ממש פה, שבה סוכמים את ההטלות שמתאימות לוקטורים הבודדים, אז מקבלים הטלה.
פה על המסך, אפשר לראות חישובים שמראים את זה ואני אשאיר לכם
לבחון אותם אם תרצו.
ובדומה לדוגמה
הראשונה, זה התנאי השני שבו האורתונורמליות
של הקבוצה משמשת.
מה שההטלה הזו עושה אם
כופלים אותה בוקטור, זה להטיל את
הוקטור על תת-המרחב שנפרש על ידי הקבוצה הזו של וקטורים,
שבצורה מופשטת זה
כמו הורדת אנך לתת-המרחב הזה, וברגע
שנמצאים בתת-המרחב הזה, ההטלה לא עושה כלום.
אז מטריצות כאלה הן
דוגמאות להטלות, ועכשיו למעשה מיצינו
את כל האפשרויות.
כל מטריצת הטלה מקבלת את הצורה הזו לבחירה כלשהי של קבוצה אורתונורמלית.
מטריצת האפס היא הטלה, אז צריך לוודא
שכוללים אותה אם רוצים לקבל כל הטלה.
אז רק כדי להבהיר, אנחנו מאפשרים את
האפשרות ש-M שווה לאפס וזה נותן לנו סכום ריק,
שאפשר לפרש כמטריצת האפס.
עכשיו שיש לנו את
המושג של הטלה לרשותנו, אפשר להגדיר מחלקה כללית יותר
של מדידות קוונטיות שנקראות מדידות הטלתיות.
זה לא המושג הכי כללי
של מדידה, אבל הוא הרבה יותר כללי ממדידות בסיס סטנדרטי
וזה יהיה מאוד
שימושי לשלב אותו בתיאור שלנו
של מידע קוונטי.
מדידה הטלתית מוגדרת על ידי כל קבוצה של הטלות
שמקיימת את התנאי שרואים ממש פה, שהוא שההטלות
סוכמות למטריצת הזהות.
פה M יכול להיות כל
מספר שלם חיובי כל עוד אלה כולן הטלות והתנאי הזה מתקיים,
האוסף מגדיר
מדידה הטלתית.
המדידה שמתוארת
על ידי אוסף כזה עובדת ככה כשמודדים
כל מצב קוונטי Psi.
קודם כל מקבלים תוצאה
בין אחד ל-M, כש-M הוא מספר ההטלות.
לכל תוצאה אפשרית K, ההסתברות לקבל את התוצאה הזו היא הנורמה האוקלידית
בריבוע של הוקטור שמקבלים
על ידי כפל Psi ב-Pi
K, ההטלה ה-K.
אפשר גם לכתוב את
הגודל הזה כמו שרואים ממש פה.
השוויון הזה בא מהקשר בין הנורמה
האוקלידית והמכפלה הפנימית יחד עם העובדה
ש-Pi K היא הטלה.
מהצורה השנייה, יחד עם התנאי שיש לנו על ההטלות האלה, אפשר לראות מיד, על ידי לינאריות, שההסתברויות
תמיד יסכמו לאחד,
עם זכירה ש-Psi
חייב להיות וקטור יחידה.
ושנית, בהנחה שקיבלנו
את התוצאה K, מצב המערכת
קורס למצב הקוונטי שמקבלים על ידי נרמול של כל
וקטור שקיבלנו מההטלה.
נסתכל על כמה
דוגמאות עוד רגע, אבל לפני כן, תנו לי להזכיר שלא באמת צריך
למספר את התוצאות
האפשריות מאחד עד M. אפשר לבחור כל שמות או סמלים שרוצים לתוצאות.
בפרט, אם יש אוסף של הטלות שמסומנות בסמלים
מקבוצה כלשהי gamma נגיד,
והן מקיימות את
אותו תנאי כמו קודם, שהוא שהן סוכמות
למטריצת הזהות, אז יש לנו מדידה הטלתית
שעובדת בדיוק
באותו אופן כמו קודם.
ההבדל היחיד פה הוא שאנחנו מאפשרים
לתוצאות המדידה להיות אלמנטים של הקבוצה gamma הזו לעומת המספרים השלמים מאחד עד M.
לדוגמה הראשונה שלנו של
מדידה הטלתית, בואו נראה שמדידות
בסיס סטנדרטי הן מדידות הטלתיות.
במקרה הזה קבוצת
התוצאות של המדידה זהה לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים של כל מערכת שנמדדת.
וקבוצת ההטלות
שמתארת את המדידה היא האוסף הזה ממש פה, בהנחה ש-sigma היא
קבוצת המצבים הקלאסית
של המערכת שלנו. אלה כולן הטלות
ואם סוכמים אותן, מקבלים את מטריצת הזהות, אז זו מדידה הטלתית תקפה
כדי לראות איך זה עובד
ביותר פירוט, בואו נניח שיש
מצב שרירותי כלשהו שכתוב בצורה
שרואים ממש פה.
ההסתברות שהמדידה
תיתן את התוצאה A, לפי התיאור
מלפני רגע, היא הערך הזה ממש פה,
ששווה לערך המוחלט
בריבוע של הכניסה המתאימה
של הוקטור Psi, שזה מה שציפינו.
בתנאי שהתוצאה היא A, מצב המערכת הופך לזה, שוב, לפי
התיאור מלפני רגע.
אם מפשטים, לא ממש
מקבלים את המצב שציפינו, שהוא Ket A.
במקום זה מקבלים Ket A
כפול סקלר, וספציפית, זה סקלר שהערך
המוחלט שלו שווה לאחד,
אז זה מספר מרוכב
על מעגל היחידה.
זה נקרא פאזה גלובלית ונדון בפאזות גלובליות בקרוב, אבל לעת עתה בקצרה, המצב
הזה שקול ל-Ket A.
הפאזה הגלובלית הזו לא
באמת בעלת משמעות כלל ונראה למה
כשנגיע לדיון על פאזות גלובליות.
אז מלבד הסוגייה של פאזות גלובליות, שנדבר עליה עוד רגע, רואים שמדידות בסיס סטנדרטי
הן בעצם מדידות הטלתיות. לדוגמה נוספת, שהיא בעצם הרחבה
של הדוגמה הקודמת,
אם מבצעים מדידת בסיס
סטנדרטי על מערכת X ולא עושים כלום למערכת Y, בדיוק כמו שדיברנו
בשיעור הקודם,
זה שקול לחלוטין
למדידת המערכת X, Y.
עם המדידה ההטלתית
הזו ממש פה.
יש לנו את ההטלות האלה שמתאימות למצבים הקלאסיים של X ומבצעים טנזור עם הזהות על Y
מה שמשקף את העובדה
שלא עושים כלום ל-Y.
התיאור של איך
מדידות הטלתיות עובדות באופן כללי אומר לנו
מה קורה בדוגמה הזו, ואני אשאיר לכם
לבדוק שזה בעצם
שקול לחלוטין למה שדנו בו בשיעור הקודם.
כל זה מאוד נחמד כי תיאור
המדידה ההטלתית הזו נקי יותר בצורה מסוימת ורואים שהוא מתאים
לתמונה הכללית יותר.
הנה עוד דוגמה אחת של
מדידה הטלתית.
זו מדידה של שני qubit.
למדידה הזו
יש שתי הטלות ולכן, שתי תוצאות
אפשריות שהן אפס ואחד.
ההטלות מוגדרות
במונחים של מצבי Bell כמו שרואים ממש פה.
ההטלה הראשונה היא
על המרחב שנפרש על ידי שלושת מצבי Bell הסימטריים וההטלה השנייה היא
על המרחב החד-ממדי
שנפרש על ידי מצב Psi-, שהוא האנטי-סימטרי, או במילים אחרות זה
שמוכפל
בסימן מינוס אם
מבצעים פעולת swap על שני ה-qubit.
נראה בהמשך הסדרה למה זו מדידה מעניינת.
לעת עתה, זו רק דוגמה
שמתחברת למשהו שכבר ראינו,
שהוא בסיס Bell.
הערה אחרונה על מדידות הטלתיות היא שבכל פעם שיש
מדידה הטלתית, תמיד אפשר לממש את המדידה הזו
באמצעות פעולות יוניטריות
ומדידות בסיס סטנדרטי.
לדוגמה הספציפית הזו
של מדידה, למשל, אפשר לבנות circuit קוונטי שמממש את המדידה
כמו שרואים ממש פה.
מדמיינים ששני ה-qubit
העליונים הם ה-qubit שמודדים
עם המדידה ההטלתית הזו ומה שאפשר לעשות זה
להציג qubit חדש
שמתחיל מאותחל
למצב אפס. מבצעים gate Hadamard
ואחריו gate Fredkin, ואחריו עוד gate Hadamard,
ואם מודדים את ה-qubit התחתון באמצעות מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי, האפקט יהיה בדיוק כאילו מדדנו את שני ה-qubit העליונים
עם המדידה ההטלתית
מהדוגמה הזו.
נקבל בדיוק את אותן הסתברויות לשתי התוצאות והאפקט שיש למדידה על שני ה-qubit העליונים
יהיה זהה גם.
זה בכלל לא מובן מאליו. נדרש ניתוח כדי לראות את זה והניתוח הזה לא מוצג פה.
כפי שכבר רמזתי, נסתכל מקרוב על
המדידה הספציפית הזו בשיעור מאוחר יותר ולעת עתה
זה רק נועד כדוגמה.
הנקודה החשובה שצריך לקחת היא שמשהו כזה
תמיד אפשרי לכל מדידה הטלתית, אז אנחנו לא באמת מרוויחים
יכולות נוספות
על ידי הצגת מדידות הטלתיות, אבל זה מושג מאוד שימושי ולעיתים קרובות נדבר
על מדידות הטלתיות
ככל שנמשיך בסדרה. החלק האחרון של השיעור הזה הוא על כמה מגבלות חשובות
של מידע קוונטי
ומה שאפשר לעשות עם circuit קוונטיים.
המגבלה הראשונה, שאולי היא לא כל כך מגבלה אלא יותר ניוון, נוגעת לסוגיית הפאזות הגלובליות
שהזכרתי לפני זמן קצר. הנה ההגדרה של מה שאנחנו מתכוונים כשמדברים על פאזה גלובלית.
אם יש לנו שני
וקטורי מצב קוונטי, Psi ו-Phi, כך שאחד מהם
שווה לשני כפול מספר מרוכב כלשהו alpha,
אז אנחנו אומרים שהמצבים
נבדלים בפאזה גלובלית או לחלופין שהם שקולים עד כדי פאזה גלובלית.
שימו לב שמכיוון שלוקטורי מצב קוונטי יש נורמה אוקלידית ששווה לאחד, הדרך היחידה שהמשוואה
הזו יכולה להתקיים
היא אם הערך המוחלט
של המספר המרוכב הזה שווה לאחד, אז alpha
חייב להיות על מעגל היחידה.
בואו נדמיין שיש לנו
שני מצבים קוונטיים כאלה שנבדלים בפאזה גלובלית ונניח שמודדים את המצב Phi
עם מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי.
ההסתברות לקבל תוצאה כלשהי A ניתנת על ידי הביטוי הזה ממש פה, ואם מציבים
alpha כפול Psi במקום Phi,
מה שאפשר לעשות כי אנחנו
מניחים שהם שווים, מקבלים את ההסתברות הזו.
ואם מפשטים באמצעות העובדה ש-alpha נמצא על
מעגל היחידה המרוכב, מקבלים את ההסתברות הזו.
זכרו שזו ההסתברות שמדידת Phi נותנת את התוצאה A, אבל עכשיו רואים
שזו בדיוק אותה הסתברות כמו מדידת
Psi שנותנת את התוצאה A,
אז אין שום
הבדל בכלל בהסתברויות של תוצאות שונות עבור שני המצבים.
טיעון דומה אומר לנו באופן כללי יותר שלכל מדידה הטלתית, ההסתברויות שוב זהות.
אז על ידי מדידה אי אפשר
להבחין בין שני מצבים
שנבדלים בפאזה גלובלית, אפילו במובן סטטיסטי.
לבסוף, אם מפעילים פעולה
יוניטרית כלשהי על המצב Phi, אז שוב על ידי הצבה, מה שנקבל הוא בדיוק
אותו מספר מרוכב alpha
כפול מה שנקבל אם נפעיל את אותה פעולה
יוניטרית על המצב Psi.
אז שני המצבים עדיין
יבדלו בפאזה גלובלית.
השורה התחתונה היא ששני המצבים לא ניתנים להבחנה לחלוטין, אז באמת אין
הבדל ביניהם בכלל
במונחים של מה שאנחנו יכולים
אולי ללמוד עליהם מביצוע פעולות
יוניטריות ומדידות ומסיבה זו,
אנחנו מתייחסים לשני
המצבים האלה כשקולים או אם מעדיפים, שאלה הם שני ייצוגים אולי שונים
בוקטורים של
אותו מצב קוונטי.
כמו שאמרתי בתחילת
הדיון, זה בעצם ניוון
באופן שבו מצבים קוונטיים מתוארים על ידי וקטורי מצב קוונטי.
בכל מקרה, מה שזה אומר הוא שאפשר
פשוט להתעלם מפאזות גלובליות בדיוק כמו שעשינו למעשה כשתיארנו מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי
כמדידות הטלתיות. אגב, הניוון הזה קורה רק בתיאור הפשוט
של מידע קוונטי.
כשמתארים מצבים
קוונטיים באמצעות מטריצות צפיפות, כפי שנעשה
ביחידה השלישית של הסדרה, יהיה לנו ייצוג
מטריצה ייחודי
לכל מצב קוונטי. סוגיית הפאזות הגלובליות
פשוט לא מתעוררת בתיאור הכללי
של מידע קוונטי.
זה עוד היבט מושך
של התיאור הכללי של מידע קוונטי,
שאני כל הזמן רומז עליו, אבל בלי קשר, פאזות
גלובליות לא יפריעו לנו
כי אנחנו יכולים פשוט
לממש את החופש שלנו להתעלם מהן.
הנה דוגמה מאוד
מהירה רק כדי לוודא שהמושג של פאזה גלובלית ברור.
אם יש לנו מצב מינוס, ומינוס אחד כפול מצב מינוס, אז שני המצבים האלה
נבדלים בפאזה גלובלית, ובפרט יש לנו
alpha שווה מינוס אחד.
מצד שני, אם יש לנו מצב פלוס ומצב מינוס, אז אין לנו שני מצבים
שנבדלים בפאזה גלובלית.
אלה וקטורים אורתוגונליים, אז הם בלתי תלויים לינארית.
לומר ששני וקטורי מצב קוונטי נבדלים בפאזה גלובלית
שקול לומר שהוקטורים תלויים לינארית,
אז בוודאי שהוקטורים האלה
לא נבדלים בפאזה גלובלית.
נכון שההבדל היחיד הוא שסימן הפלוס הזה
הופך לסימן המינוס הזה, אבל זה מה שקוראים
להבדל פאזה יחסי.
זה שונה מפאזה גלובלית כי אנחנו לא
כופלים את כל הוקטור במספר מרוכב.
וזה עקבי עם העובדה שאפשר להבחין
בין המצבים האלה, בפרט, אם
מפעילים פעולת Hadamard
ואז מודדים, נראה אפס אם
המצב היה מצב פלוס ואחד אם המצב היה מצב מינוס.
המגבלה הבאה של מידע קוונטי שנראה בשיעור הזה
היא משפט אי-השכפול.
הנה ניסוח אחד של
משפט אי-השכפול והניסוח הספציפי
הזה של המשפט הוא די קונקרטי וספציפי,
מה שיקל על הדיון בו. יש דרכים כלליות יותר לנסח את משפט אי-השכפול,
אבל נתמקד בזה לעת עתה.
אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו שתי מערכות X ו-Y שיש להן את אותה קבוצת מצבים קלאסית.
שמורכבת מהמספרים
השלמים מאפס עד D-1 כש-D הוא לפחות שניים.
זה לא באמת חשוב מה השמות של המצבים הקלאסיים, אבל בבחירת השמות האלה זה יעזור לשמור על פשטות.
מה שהכי חשוב
פה הוא שיש לפחות שני מצבים קלאסיים
שונים, אז במילים אחרות, אנחנו לא מודאגים מהמקרה
הטריוויאלי ולא מעניין
שבו יש רק מצב קלאסי אחד.
מה שהמשפט אומר הוא שאין פעולה יוניטרית U שאפשר להפעיל על X, Y כך שאם מאתחלים
את Y למצב אפס,
אנחנו למעשה מעתיקים או משכפלים
מצבים קוונטיים שרירותיים של X.
אם מסתכלים על
הביטוי הזה ממש פה בבידוד, מה שהוא אומר הוא שלכל בחירה של וקטור מצב קוונטי Psi של X,
הפעלת U על Psi טנזור
מצב האפס, נותנת לנו Psi טנזור Psi, או במילים אחרות שני
עותקים עצמאיים של Psi,
אז זה מה שזה היה אומר אם יכולנו לשכפל מצבים
קוונטיים ומה שהמשפט אומר הוא שזה לא אפשרי.
אפשר לחשוב על זה
במונחים של circuit ומה שהמשפט אומר הוא
שלעולם לא תוכלו למצוא gate או circuit
שעובד כמו שרואים פה.
שבו עותק אחד של המצב Psi נכנס ביחד עם אוסף
של qubit מאותחלים ושני עותקים של Psi נוצרים.
אפשר לעשות את זה לבחירות
מסוימות של המצב Psi, אבל לעולם אי אפשר למצוא
circuit שעובד ככה לכל מצב קוונטי Psi,
וזה מה שהמשפט אומר.
זה די קל להוכיח
את המשפט הזה, למעשה, זה בעצם מסתכם בעובדה שהטרנספורמציה שאנחנו
מחפשים היא לא לינארית,
אבל פעולות יוניטריות הן
לינאריות, אז זה פשוט לא יכול לעבוד.
הנה טיעון בקצת יותר פירוט.
נניח שיש לנו פעולה יוניטרית U שמשכפלת את מצבי הבסיס
הסטנדרטי, Ket 0 ו-Ket אחד.
אנחנו יודעים שהמצבים
הקלאסיים אפס ואחד חייבים להיות שייכים לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסית שלנו כי D הוא לפחות שניים.
אבל זה אומר מלינאריות
שאם X במצב פלוס, שאפשר לכתוב ככה,
אז התוצאה היא הצירוף הלינארי הזה של שני המצבים האלה ממש פה.
אבל זה לא ההתנהגות הנכונה. הדרישה מ-U היא ש-U
משכפל את מצב הפלוס,
מה שאומר שהמשוואה
הזו ממש פה צריכה להתקיים.
שני המצבים האלה לא
זהים ולכן זה לא עובד וזה הכל.
רק כמה הערות נוספות
על משפט אי-השכפול.
ראשית, הניסוח הזה של
משפט אי-השכפול הוא מוחלט במובן מסוים.
הוא פשוט אומר שפעולה יוניטרית U שעובדת בדיוק
ככה לא קיימת.
אז אפשר לשאול האם
קיימת פעולה יוניטרית U שעושה
את זה בקירוב ביחס לאיזושהי דרך לתאר
קירוב לניסוח. יש מושגים שונים
של קירוב שאולי מעניינים
ונראה כמה
מהם ביחידה השלישית של הסדרה, אבל למושגים השונים
האלה של קירוב,
יש ניסוחים כמותיים
של משפט אי-השכפול ששמים גבולות חזקים על כמה טוב אפשר לשכפל בקירוב.
הערה שנייה היא שהעתקה או שכפול של מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי בהחלט
אפשרי.
למשל, gate NOT מבוקר מעתיק את מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי של qubit.
זה לא סותר
את משפט אי-השכפול. הנקודה היא ששכפול במובן של משפט אי-השכפול דורש
שזה יעבוד לא רק
למצבי בסיס סטנדרטי
אלא לכל המצבים.
gate NOT מבוקר
בוודאי לא משכפל מצב פלוס למשל.
ולבסוף, שווה לציין שיש גם משפט אי-שכפול למצבים
הסתברותיים.
זה פשוט לא משהו
שאנשים מדברים עליו או שאכפת להם ממנו.
אם מישהו בוחר
ביט באקראי, למשל, לפי איזושהי דרך שרירותית
לשייך הסתברויות לשני הערכים ואז
נותן לכם את הביט,
כמובן שאין דרך להשיג שני דגימות עצמאיות
של הביט האקראי הזה.
אתם פשוט לא יודעים מה
ההסתברויות.
אפשר להעתיק את הביט בדיוק כמו ש-NOT מבוקר
מעתיק מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי, אבל זה לא אותו דבר כמו שכפול המצב ההסתברותי.
פשוט אין לכם מספיק
מידע לעשות את זה. כל ביט אקראי שקיבלתם לא אומר לכם מה
ההסתברויות היו.
זה סתם ביט.
חוסר האפשרות לשכפל
מצב הסתברותי נובע מבדיוק אותו היגיון כמו בהגדרה הקוונטית.
שכפול הוא תהליך לא-לינארי, בעוד שפעולות הסתברותיות, בדיוק כמו פעולות יוניטריות, הן לינאריות.
בכל מקרה, זה לא מפתיע
שאי אפשר לשכפל מצב הסתברותי ו
איכשהו זה לא מעניין כמו העובדה שאי אפשר
לשכפל מצב קוונטי,
אבל הנקודה היא פשוט לראות שזו לא תופעה קוונטית
ייחודית.
המגבלה האחרונה
של מידע קוונטי שנדון בה בשיעור הזה היא שאי אפשר
להבחין באופן מושלם
בין שני מצבים קוונטיים שאינם אורתוגונליים.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה
היא שאם שני מצבים קוונטיים ניתנים להבחנה מושלמת, אז הם חייבים להיות אורתוגונליים.
מה שאנחנו מתכוונים כשמדברים
על הבחנה מושלמת של שני מצבים קוונטיים, Psi ו-Phi, היא שיש דרך כלשהי
להבדיל ביניהם
בלי שום סיכוי לטעות.
במונחים של מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי, אפשר לבטא את זה כמו
שרואים פה על המסך.
יש איזושהי פעולה יוניטרית U, שיכולה להיות ממומשת
כ-circuit קוונטי או שאפשר פשוט לחשוב על U באופן מופשט
כפעולה יוניטרית
וכקלט U מקבל את המצב Psi או את המצב Phi
ביחד עם חבורה של qubit מאותחלים, שאפשר לחשוב עליהם כ-qubit סביבת עבודה שאיכשהו מסייעים בתהליך
ההבחנה הזה.
אחרי שמפעילים את U, ה-qubit העליון נמדד ביחס למדידת בסיס סטנדרטי והנה חלק
ההבחנה המושלמת.
אם מצב הקלט היה Psi, אז המדידה חייבת
לתת את התוצאה אפס, 100% מהזמן, ואם
מצב הקלט היה Phi,
אז המדידה חייבת
לתת את התוצאה אחד, שוב עם 100% סיכוי.
לא חשוב מה
המצבים של ה-qubit האחרים האלה אחרי שהופעל U.
כל מה שחשוב זה הביט הזה שמקבלים מהמדידה כי זה הביט שאומר לנו עם איזה משני המצבים התחלנו.
לבחירות מסוימות של מצבים, Psi ו-Phi, יהיה אפשר לבצע הבחנה מושלמת כזו
ולאחרות לא.
ומה שנראה הוא שאם
אפשר לעשות את זה, אז Psi ו-Phi חייבים
להיות מצבים אורתוגונליים
וזה אומר שאם Phi ו-Psi
לא אורתוגונליים, אי אפשר להבחין ביניהם באופן מושלם.
אז בואו נראה למה הבחנה מושלמת גוררת אורתוגונליות.
נתחיל בכתיבת שתי משוואות שמבטאות את מה ששני
התרשימים האלה מבטאים.
אם חושבים על המצב הקוונטי שמקבלים אחרי הפעלת U על
חבורה של qubit מאותחלים יחד עם המצב Psi,
רואים שחייב להיות
לו הצורה הזו ממש פה, כש-Pi אפס הוא איזשהו וקטור מצב קוונטי שמייצג את המצב
של כל ה-qubit האלה
חוץ מהעליון. אין לנו שום מידע
על המצב הקוונטי הזה, Pi אפס, הוא יכול להיות כל דבר,
אבל אנחנו יודעים שכל
המצב חייב להיראות ככה כי זו הדרך
היחידה שהמדידה מובטחת לתת את
התוצאה אפס, 100% מהזמן.
ויש לנו משוואה
אנלוגית לשני.
הפעם ה-qubit העליון
חייב להיות במצב אחד ובדומה ל-Pi אפס,
המצב Pi אחד יכול להיות כל דבר.
ובנוסף לכך שאין
לנו מידע על Pi אחד, אנחנו גם לא יודעים
כלום על הקשר בין Pi אפס ו-Pi אחד.
ככל שידוע לנו, אלה פשוט שני
מצבים קוונטיים שרירותיים.
מה שאפשר לעשות עכשיו זה
לכפול את שני הצדדים של המשוואות האלה
בשני הצדדים ב-U dagger, כלומר הצמוד המשוחלף של U.
ואם עושים את זה, מקבלים את שתי המשוואות
שרואים ממש פה.
אנחנו משתמשים בעובדה ש-U dagger כפול U היא מטריצת הזהות.
ולכן לא רואים U או U dagger בצד שמאל של אף אחת מהמשוואות.
ועכשיו אפשר לשקול את המכפלה הפנימית בין Psi ו-Phi.
היא זהה למכפלה
הפנימית של Psi ו-Phi כפול המכפלה הפנימית
של מצב האפס ל-L עם עצמו
כי המכפלה הפנימית של
כל מצב עם עצמו היא אחד וזה כולל את מצב האפס ל-L.
ועכשיו אם מסתכלים על שתי המשוואות שלנו, רואים שהביטוי הזה פה שווה למכפלה הפנימית של הוקטורים
שמיוצגים על ידי שתי המשוואות. ובפרט זו המכפלה הפנימית בין הצדדים
השמאליים של המשוואות האלה.
אז אפשר באותה מידה
לבטא את המכפלה הפנימית הזו כמכפלה הפנימית של הוקטורים שמיוצגים על ידי הצדדים
הימניים של המשוואות,
כי הצד השמאלי שווה
לצד הימני בשתי המשוואות.
אז מקבלים את הביטוי הזה ממש פה, שהוא המכפלה הפנימית
של שני הצדדים הימניים של המשוואות או באופן שקול,
זה הצמוד המשוחלף של הראשון כפול השני.
U כפול U dagger שווה
למטריצת הזהות, כי U יוניטרית ולכן זה נעלם.
ואפשר לפשט קצת כדי לקבל את המכפלה של
המכפלות הפנימיות האלה.
עכשיו זכרו שאנחנו לא יודעים כלום על הקשר
בין Pi אפס ו-Pi אחד, אז אנחנו לא יודעים מה
המכפלה הפנימית שלהם.
זה מסתורין עבורנו. אבל מה שזה לא יהיה, אנחנו כופלים אותו במכפלה הפנימית של Ket 0 ו-Ket אחד, שהיא אפס.
אז התוצאה הסופית היא
שמקבלים את הערך אפס, אבל זה מה שרצינו להראות, המכפלה הפנימית בין
Psi ו-Phi שווה לאפס.
אז שני המצבים אורתוגונליים.
אז אל תטרחו לנסות
להבחין באופן מושלם בין שני מצבים קוונטיים
לא-אורתוגונליים, פשוט אי אפשר לעשות את זה.
יש הפוך לטענה
שהוכחנו, שהוא שמצבים קוונטיים אורתוגונליים תמיד ניתנים להבחנה מושלמת,
וזה לא כל כך קשה
לראות אם משתמשים בעובדה שהזכרתי קודם בשיעור.
ספציפית אם Psi ו-Phi
הם מצבים אורתוגונליים, אז דבר אחד שאפשר לעשות הוא לבחור מטריצה יוניטרית U כלשהי
ששתי העמודות הראשונות
שלה הן שני המצבים.
אנחנו יודעים שתמיד
אפשר לעשות את זה ולא חשוב
לצורך המשימה הזו בדיוק איך המטריצה היוניטרית נבחרת.
כל מה שחשוב הוא שאלה שתי העמודות הראשונות.
לא צריך qubit נוספים. אם פשוט מפעילים את U על
שני המצבים האפשריים, אז נקבל את
שתי התוצאות האפשריות האלה.
ואם מודדים את ה-qubit העליון ביותר, שזכרו הוא ה-qubit הימני ביותר, אז נקבל אפס או אחד
תלוי באיזה מצב התחלנו.
לחלופין, אפשר לשקול
מדידה הטלתית עם תוצאות אפס ואחד
שמוגדרת כמו שרואים ממש פה.
במקרה הזה, המדידה
בעצם תלויה רק ב-Psi.
המדידה הזו מבחינה
באופן מושלם בין Psi לכל מצב שאורתוגונלי ל-Psi.
אם מודדים Psi ביחס למדידה ההטלתית הזו, אז נקבל את התוצאה
אפס בהסתברות אחד כמו שהמשוואות האלה מראות.
ולכל מצב Phi
שאורתוגונלי ל-Psi, נקבל את התוצאה
אחד בהסתברות אחד.
לא אעבור על
הפרטים של החישובים האלה, אבל אם מעוניינים, אני מעודד אתכם לעבור
על הפרטים בעצמכם.
וזהו סוף שיעור שלוש. כיסינו הרבה
חומר בשיעור הזה, כולל circuit קוונטיים,
מכפלות פנימיות ואורתונורמליות, הטלות ומדידות הטלתיות, העובדה שפאזות גלובליות לא משנות,
משפט אי-השכפול, והעובדה שמצבים לא-אורתוגונליים אי אפשר להבחין ביניהם באופן מושלם בעוד שמצבים אורתוגונליים כן.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי
לשיעור הרביעי בקרוב, שהוא השיעור האחרון
ביחידה הראשונה של הסדרה.
בשיעור הרביעי, נדבר על שלוש
דוגמאות חשובות מאוד, טלפורטציה, קידוד על-צפוף,
ואי-שוויון CHSH או משחק CHSH כמו שלפעמים מתארים.
להתראות עד אז,